hacemos
ha pasado un mes desde que huyeron der
pin pero todavía su hijo pequeño sigue
con pesadillas y tiene miedo de salir a
la calle pero gracias a la hospitalidad
de dima esta familia ha encontrado no
sólo un refugio sino un hogar y nos
acabamos de ocupar una nueva casa
presidirán nos iban a dar las llaves no
sé en qué condiciones está mi madre y yo
estamos preocupadas pero prefiero no
decirles nada a los niños está termines
nam
dima está acostumbrado a vivir solo pero
ahora que tiene una nueva familia le
gusta pasar parte de su tiempo con ella
y en los días que no llueve y hace menos
frío saca la mesa de comer al jardín
sentí que no estaba haciendo nada para
ayudar a los ucranianos así que ofrecí
mi casa una familia joven e intento que
aquí al menos puedan estar tranquilos
que puedan tener su propio espacio
moldavia está hombro con hombro con
ucrania frente a la invasión rusa y ha
mostrado su apoyo recibiendo más de
350.000 ucranianos que han huido de la
guerra bolsas de comida ropa juguetes
donados
cada día este almacén de ayuda
humanitaria organizado por un batallón
de voluntarios
al principio recibimos mucha ayuda de la
gente local pero cada vez menos la
situación económica es mala estamos
buscando otros canales para seguir
ayudando
pequeños gestos solidarios que para
refugiados como tania y olga se
convierten en muy grandes
moldavia se ha convertido en un ejemplo
de solidaridad para miles de refugiados
pero a medida que el conflicto en su
país vecino parece estancarse pone a
prueba la economía de uno de los países
más pobres de europa